Okay. All right. I heard that. It's the Thursday sigh. One more day.
Yeah, there we go. The Thursday sigh. It's Thursday, July 25th.
President Biden explained his decision to step aside in a speech from the Oval Office.
I've decided the best way forward is to pass the torch for a new generation.
What's on the agenda for his remaining time in office?
I'm Stephen Skeep with Michelle Martin, and this is Up First from NPR News.
Israel's Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu meets President Biden today
and will meet separately with Vice President Harris,
where do the President and Vice President differ on Israel and Gaza?
And voters are paying attention to how Kamala Harris' record on law enforcement
could play out in a contest against Donald Trump.
When you can say this is a clear case of a prosecutor against a felon,
it's a home run.
Stay with us. We'll give you the news you need to start your day.
This message comes from NPR sponsor IBM.
Things will go wrong for your customers,
but your business can make it right with WatsonX Assistant,
AI that can help resolve problems by understanding your customer requests
with 90% accuracy.
Let's create customer service in service of customers with WatsonX Assistant.
Learn more at IBM.com slash Assistant. IBM, let's create.
This message comes from NPR sponsor Capital One.
Capital One offers checking accounts with no fees or minimums and no overdraft fees.
That's banking, reimagined.
What's in your wallet?
Terms apply.
See capitalone.com slash bank. Capital One NA member FDIC.
This message comes from Progressive Insurance,
where drivers who save by switching save nearly $750 on average.
Get your quote at progressive.com and see if you could save.
Progressive Casualty Insurance Company and Affiliates.
National average 12 month savings of $744 by new customers surveyed
who saved with progressive between June 2022 and May 2023.
Potential savings will vary.
President Biden did not want to end his bid for reelection,
but he said the stakes were just too high to risk it.
I believe I reckon as president, my leadership in the world,
my vision for America's future, all married at a second term,
but nothing, nothing can come in the way of saving our democracy.
That includes personal ambition.
So I've decided the best way forward is to pass the torch for a new generation.
The president spoke of his decision to step aside
and also asserted that he still has work to do
in his final six months behind the Oval Office desk
from which he addressed the nation.
Joining us now to talk more about this
is NPR senior White House correspondent Tamra Keith
up again early after a long night, Tam.
Yeah, good morning.
Thanks for doing that.
So what was Biden trying to accomplish with this address?
Well, this was a monumental moment for Biden,
marking the end or at least the beginning of the end
of a very long career in public life.
And his family sat lining the walls of the Oval Office as he spoke.
The first lady, his grandkids, his kids,
he spoke as Steve said from behind the resolute desk,
this place of very serious presidential addresses.
And this was about explaining the very difficult decision
he made to step aside
and putting it in a noble light.
He was also making an appeal to the American people
to think about what kind of country they want.
At the very end,
Biden delivered this emotional expression of gratitude,
saying that he had given his heart and soul to the nation
over 50 years in public life
and has been blessed with the love and support
of the American people.
I hope you have some idea how grateful I am to all of you.
The great thing about America is here,
kings and dictators do not rule, the people do.
This wasn't the place for the overtly political language
you would hear at a campaign rally.
So he never said former President Trump's name,
but the subtext was quite clear.
It was clear,
but you know the speech had the feeling of a farewell address,
Tam, but he still has six months left in office.
What did he say he wants to do at the time he is left?
You know, it really felt like the oxygen drained out of his presidency
when he announced he was dropping out of the race for reelection.
But practically speaking, this term was already in a lame duck phase.
His biggest achievements happened
before Democrats lost control of the House in 2023.
So a lot of what he can do in these final months is implementation,
distributing funds for infrastructure and climate projects,
cementing regulations.
He said he is going to keep fighting for reproductive rights
and civil rights.
He's going to keep working on the economy and trying to lower costs
and he'll speak out against extremism and political violence.
And of course, he is still trying very hard to get a ceasefire
for hostages deal in Gaza.
Tam, we have a lot of time to talk about this,
but at the end of the day, how do you think his legacy will be defined?
Well, you know, there's been a lot of praise from Democrats
about Biden's selflessness since his announcement on Sunday,
but the real judgment comes in November.
By realizing he needed to step aside at this very late date,
he foreclosed any possibility of a real primary.
Right now, Democrats are very excited about Vice President Harris
as the likely nominee, but this race is still very close.
If Harris wins, Biden will be remembered as the rare president
who put his party and country ahead of his ego.
If she loses, then he is both the person who removed Trump from office
and ushered him back in.
That is N.P.S. Tamara Keith waking up early again after another late night.
Tam, thank you.
You're welcome.
Israel's Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu spoke to the U.S. Congress again yesterday.
He's given addresses to Congress four different times,
which is more than any foreign leader in history.
He's been around for a while.
Netanyahu's latest yesterday included flourishes
often seen in a presidential state-of-the-union address.
He told stories of guests in the audience to illustrate
and defend Israel's war against Hamas.
For the forces of civilization to triumph,
America and Israel must stand together.
Today, the Prime Minister meets President Biden at the White House
and also meets with Vice President Harris
how she engages Netanyahu matters more now that she's running for president.
NPR White House correspondent Asma Khaled is with us now to tell us more about that.
Good morning, Asma.
Good morning.
I wanted to ask you how you characterize the Vice President's policies on Gaza.
I mean, obviously, she's the Vice President,
so you assume that her policies would have to be in lockstep with the presidents.
But what would you say about how she approaches the issue?
Well, the substance of what she's saying is similar to Biden,
but she differs in style and tone.
Harris did describe her as having a, quote,
unwavering commitment to the security of Israel.
I also talked with an advisor from Harris's days in the Senate, Hailey Soyfer,
who told me what it was like at a recent White House event
in which she saw the Vice President take on a real leadership role
in condemning the use of sexual violence in the October 7th attacks.
But really, Michelle, the real difference from Biden
is how Harris talks about people in Gaza.
Take a listen to her comments from this past March in Selma, Alabama.
What we are seeing every day in Gaza is devastating.
We have seen reports of families eating leaves or animal feed.
Women giving birth to malnourished babies with little or no medical care.
I've spoken with multiple people who've remarked to me
that Harris shows a greater degree of empathy for Palestinian civilians
than they have heard publicly from Biden.
Have these words affected how voters see her?
Well, people I've spoken with in the Arab-American community
say that Harris is not viewed as being as toxic as Biden.
I was speaking to Rubel Roman.
She's a Democratic Georgia state legislator, a Palestinian American,
and she put it this way.
I can tell you right now that if I had, for example,
tried to go to a mosque or Arab community event
and urged them to vote for Joe Biden,
I would never be invited back.
The anger was so deep and the hurt was so deep.
Even for me, I tell people that.
And I think people would at least be open to hearing from her
and to let her make her case.
And some Democrats who voted uncommitted during the primaries
told me that they're willing to give Harris a chance.
I mean, to be clear, they are not saying they will definitively vote for her,
but there's a possibility.
I'll also say that Harris was one of the earlier people in the administration
to show a less dismissive response to some of the protests here at home.
Today, she is meeting separately with Israel's Prime Minister,
separately from Biden.
What do you expect from her meeting?
What I'm watching for is how closely she sticks to the president.
You know, she inherits this problem now in her campaign
and following the attack in October that killed more than 1,200 people.
There are now more than 39,000 Palestinians who've been killed
and there's still no ceasefire.
And some people will blame her because she is a part of this administration.
She has a real delicate balancing act
where she's going to try not to alienate supporters of Israel
who make up a key part of the Democratic Party,
but she's also trying to win back some of the young, progressive, brown and black voters
whom Biden alienated with some of his decisions about this war.
That is NPR's Asma Khaled. Asma, thank you.
Good to talk to you.
Vice President Harris faces another fundamental challenge to win the election.
The likely Democratic nominee will have to hold together a broad coalition,
and they have some very different views on some issues.
President Biden managed this in 2020, but the coalition has frayed
as we've just heard, and Harris is a different figure.
Her challenge becomes plain what comes to her record in law enforcement.
My co-host Steve Inskeep has been talking with voters in western Pennsylvania.
Steve, what did you find out?
Well, some contrasting opinions of a big part of Harris's resume.
Her history as a San Francisco prosecutor in California Attorney General.
She raised this in her first campaign event
while running for president talking of Donald Trump and saying,
as a prosecutor, she knew what a predator was or a fraudster.
How voters take that message depends on who you talk to.
On NPR's Morning Edition yesterday, we heard Kathleen Madonna Emerling,
a Democratic Party activist in the Pittsburgh suburbs,
who really likes her new candidate.
My first thought was, this is the ideal suburban candidate
because she straddles the line between being approachable,
relatable, joyful event, while also having incredible public safety credentials.
Because often in the suburbs, people want someone who is pro-public safety, pro-police.
Because many people in her suburb have military or police backgrounds.
And when you can say, this is a clear case of a prosecutor against a felon, it's a home run.
Although for some people in the Democratic Coalition, Michelle, this is a more complicated subject.
And I can co-sign that because I have, as they say, people of that way where you are.
So what is another way people see the vice president's record?
As a potential mark against her.
I also went into central Pittsburgh this week to the Hill District,
which is a historically black neighborhood, and talked with Adrienne Dilworth.
She said she had mixed feelings about Harris.
We spoke here while dodging cars in a grocery store parking lot.
I think they should have put out a broader net for candidates to see who could be actually the best
and not just, you know, like, okay, we're just going to push the VP for the position.
Why do you have mixed feelings about vice president Harris?
Just some of her history.
We better get away from this.
It would be bad for the interview if you run over in the middle here.
Yeah, no, we're not going to have that.
From just some of what I'm hearing from what of her history of some of the people that she's had incarcerated in the past.
She was referring to part of Harris' record as a prosecutor.
She fought to put people in prison.
Sometimes she clashed with civil rights groups and activists over her decisions.
And she's been attacked over the years on the left for this.
Now the attack is being repeated by Republicans.
I guess you could say that Republicans are just trolling here,
but they are also explicitly seeking some of the black vote for Donald Trump.
And you can see where that might resonate with some people in a community that has had this complicated, as you say, relationship with law enforcement.
Oh, yeah, I've interviewed people in that same neighborhood in past years,
and I once met a voter who was 22 and said she'd already been jailed twice for things that she said she didn't do.
So to hold together that Democratic coalition, Harris needs law and order people
and also people who are skeptical of law and order as it is sometimes practiced in the United States,
and we can expect her record to be scrutinized.
Although I should add in that same neighborhood, I also found people who were very eager to vote for Harris,
excited to vote for a woman, and they were organizing with a new intensity.
That is Steve Inskiep in Pittsburgh. Steve, thank you.
Glad to do it.
And that's up first for Thursday, July 25th. I'm Michelle Martin.
And I'm Steve Inskiep. Consider this.
Kamala Harris will not be the first woman to lead a major party's presidential ticket,
but will be the first woman of color.
And though her nomination is not yet official, she's already the subject of racist attacks.
How does that affect her candidacy? Listen to consider this.
Today's episode of Up First was edited by Roberta Rampton, Gabriel Spitzer, Dana Farrington,
Janea Williams, and Alice Wolfley.
It was produced by Ziad Butch, Ben Abrams, and Milton Guevara.
We get engineering support from Carly Strange and our technical director, Zach Coleman.
We hope you'll join us again tomorrow.
This message comes from NPR sponsor Mint Mobile.
From the gas pump to the grocery store, inflation is everywhere.
So Mint Mobile is offering premium wireless starting at just $15 a month.
To get your new phone plan for just $15, go to mintmobile.com.slashswitch.
This message comes from NPR sponsor Warby Parker.
Their glasses start at $95, including anti-reflective scratch-resistant prescription lenses
that block 100% of UV rays.
Try five pairs of frames at home for free.
Go to warbyparker.com.slashcovered.